achieving a week alone I think the week
is a great addition to the landscape of
sports in this country it gives us an
opportunity to highlight the great stuff
that is going on but also to talk about
these statistics and really get into
them and why they exist and what we can
do as the sports industry but as the
media as commercial investors as a whole
and as the country as a whole to really
lift it up for the health benefits for
the academic benefits for the growth of
business and ultimately to bring more to
our society need to look at some of
things that happened in recent years the
2012 Olympics for example so the
televising of the boat race of the first
time ever women's boat race that is how
much of a difference is that kind of
thing it makes a huge difference we
don't expect things to change overnight
they will change gradually but they must
change helena morrissey absolutely
spearheaded that the women's boat race
change bring any investment in here and
that was really really important it
gives women a place next two men on the
river on the track in the boardroom in
the changing rooms at schools on the
school pictures as well and in the
classroom this is about the quality and
society and the sports is a huge part of
that and it's a great opportunity to be
at the forefront of some change but at
the same time is quite shocking to read
that for example and it comes to
professional players and cricket or
football even actually that being paid
for that was quite a relative things but
how do you actually encourage women to
take up sports and a professional career
I think it's much more about how do we
get them to enjoy being physically
active weather that sport or physical
activity is a young age and through that
making sure that we work closely with
national governing body so that there is
a pathway for the talented but that
everyone can remain active at all times
in whatever sport they want to do how
they want to do it and it doesn't matter
how they looks about how they feel yeah
I think it's teenage girls isn't it
whether it seemed to make actually this
isn't cool anymore you know I'm place
what I get hot and sweaty how do you
change that I think the sport England's
this girl can campaign has done so much
to really recognize the biggest thing
that women and girls seem to struggle
with is that fear of judgment and the
campaign is giving them an opportunity
to say I jig also what you know I do so
what that's not going to stop me moving
it's really making it accessible
appropriate and just as much for women
and girls as it is for boys and men and
just make brief if you will what should
girls do this weekend do whatever they
want to do more than anything else not
be ashamed of it get on you know I'm
london-based we've got a great website
called get active London calm go on
there as a women's only section and I'll
tell you what you whatever you might
want to do there will be an opportunity
for you and don't be afraid to do it and
take your mom your sister your auntie
long to very good advice and what's more
fun in a group good evening thank you